hey youtubers it's Charlie so it was
just announced the TNT might be doing a
Teen Titans live-action show just called
Titans so this video is gonna be a
breakdown of what's going on with that
deal and what the show might look like
in the tradition of arrow it would just
be called Titans it's not being done by
the same group of people that are doing
air on the flash but they have announced
a couple of the characters and said you
know what the state of the production is
hello it's any new people if you're just
finding me for the first time there are
four new DC Comics TV shows coming this
fall including Gotham arrow the flash
and Constantine I want to be doing
videos for all of them so be sure to
subscribe to get everything it's gonna
be a really fun season whenever they
announced the Teen Titans news a bunch
of you guys asked me questions on
Twitter and Facebook the biggest being
you know who's on the team and is it
gonna connect with the other DC TV shows
right now they've only named three team
members including Nightwing Starfire and
Raven the same way that arrow and the
flash have been casting superheroes they
use their real names so like the Teen
Titans show list Nightwing as Dick
Grayson like they cast Dick Grayson they
didn't cast Nightwing I know it sounds a
little bit weird it's just like whatever
they cast stuff in Hollywood they
usually list like the actual person's
name they don't list like the alias
right now there are no official plans to
connect it to the DC TV universe in the
way that arrow the flash Constantine and
Gotham are all loosely connected it's
really up to TNT how much they want to
connect with those other shows but it's
a different network and really to be
honest only arrow and the flash have
confirmed they're doing full-blown
crossovers and that's because they're
both on the same network they're both on
the CW I'll explain how the DC TV
universe is gonna work in a sec but
essentially this New Teen Titans show
would be a one-hour drama basically all
the big DC TV shows right now are 1-hour
dramas the current state of the
production deal is that it's still at
the pilot stage meaning that TNT is
still waiting to approve the pilot for
production if they say yes
TNT would pay like four or five million
dollars to Warner Brothers to produce a
pilot episode
then if TNT greenlit the series they
would basically give them like a couple
Episode order if those go well then they
pick it up for a full season you know in
each season thereafter they just pick it
up or cancel it for a full season that's
typically the way TV shows work there's
no confirmation as to whether they're
planning this is like a 10 episode thing
or 20 episode or 23 like it is on the
seed
you each network is just a little bit
different they do want this Teen Titan
show to work and the mere fact that it
was announced publicly means that
there's a really good chance that it's
all gonna work out just fine
right now the only real exception with
all these new shows is that Gotham on
Fox whenever they basically paid the
dump truck of money to Warner Brothers
to produce the series picked it up for
like a full series when it was still at
the pilot stage it usually doesn't
happen that way usually it takes a
couple episodes before I show it gets
picked up for a full season TNT doesn't
have Fox levels of money to throw around
but they do need a superhero genre show
to pull in a slightly younger
demographic if you want to know what the
show might look like just think about
the other shows that TNT is running
right now and how a new superhero drama
might fit in with those so let's just
take a look at what's on TNT right now
Sean beans show legends that's brand new
major crimes murder in the first
perception cold justice and then reruns
of Supernatural Smallville and other
young demo shows TNT right now is like
the informative murder porn channel for
those that haven't watched that South
Park episode you should totally watch it
it's on Hulu for free so any superhero
show they would do it polite combined
some of the feel they're syndicated
shows you know for the younger demo with
some of the gritty hardcore aspects of
informative murder porn that older
people watch just to give you an idea of
what TNT programs for is essentially
people ages 25 to 54 usually skewing
towards the older end of that
demographic the mere fact that they want
to do a superhero show implies that
they're trying to pull in younger
viewers and most people that watch those
shows are in the 18 to 34 demographic so
mention like a bloodier more sexed up
version of arrow I mean it's on TNT
which is cable so they have a lot more
latitude with what they can show but
essentially Warner Brothers isn't gonna
let them do like an informative murder
porn TV show a good analog to think of
is Gotham on Fox
Gotham is a network show and they want
it to be really dark really gritty
because it is Batman but since that's a
major network they have a lot more
considerations in terms of censorship
that they have to deal with the other
strike I think in its favor is that TNT
isn't making an animated show marketed
to children it just means they won't
have to pull as many punches in terms of
what they show on TV so the other big
question I've seen you guys ask is you
know who's writing this who's behind it
it's not the same team that's behind err
in the flash
the two riders that are on the project
are Akiva Goldsman and Marc Ames most
people remember Goldsman is the person
that wrote Batman Forever and Batman and
Robin you know those aren't necessarily
strikes in his favor but he also wrote
on Fringe for a long time so I'm
optimistic Hames isn't really known for
his writing he used to be an executive
at DreamWorks I don't know that he still
is essentially the story for that pilot
episode has already been written that's
how they sold the project they would
have had to write an entire story first
TNT is really just finalizing the deal
so this is happening but it doesn't
guarantee that the show is gonna make it
the series if you remember during the
Smallville era Warner Brothers tried to
get a Blue Beetle show off the ground
they even shot a pilot episode Geoff
Johns totally brought footage as a Comic
Con but it never turned into a series so
there have been big DC TV shows that
just fizzled out in various stages of
development in terms of what the story
that pilot might be I'm guessing that
it's going to be something of an origin
story just because they've only listed
three characters otherwise they would
had the full team so whenever it picks
up they probably won't be the Teen
Titans and since it's on TNT with the
slightly older skewing demo I'm
picturing you know mid to late
20-something characters so this won't be
a high school version of Teen Titans
it's not gonna be like Buffy and the
other big question is is you know which
characters are they gonna bring on
obviously the flash is going crazy with
superheroes in season one but because
TNT is a different network I think it's
gonna be a little bit different whenever
arrow first started it really took its
time introducing characters from the
comics even though the Titan show will
probably share some DNA with those shows
I don't expect to see a lot of new
Titans members in season one I do expect
that we'll see one of the big comic book
villains though there's no way you could
do a big comic book series with a big
comic book team without having a big
comic book villain here's a couple
possibilities for villains I think that
they could use theirs Trigon obviously
they're doing Raven they can do Trigon
there's hive the organization Vandal
Savage Cheshire and the calculator I
don't think that Warner Brothers would
let them use Deathstroke just because
era already did the character but he is
one of the more infamous Teen Titans
villains whenever new shows inside the
DC Universe want to use characters they
have to get approved by Warner Brothers
and DC Comics for example during the
arrow panel at Comic Con Andrew
Kreisberg said that initially when they
were planning
arrow season 3 they wanted to use Ted
Kord as the Blue Beetle they'd already
laid all these Kord industries Easter
eggs everywhere so it's only natural
they'd bring them on eventually but
Warner Brothers said we have other plans
for that character so naturally they
made Brandon routes character the Ray
Palmer atom so rethinking Chris Burke's
comments about the Blue Beetle makes me
wonder if this new Titan show is gonna
incorporate Ted Kord it's not a
confirmation or anything but Warner
Brothers did have other plans
quote-unquote for a live-action Ted Kord
and it's probably not gonna be for
Batman vs Superman of course if
everything works out eventually I'd love
to see Tim Drake Beast Boy Wonder Girls
Superboy joined the team the long shots
are Superboy and Wonder Girl just
because Superman and Wonder Woman's
personas have typically been filmed only
it is totally possible we could see a TV
version of Conner Kent someday probably
not that soon just because you'd have to
explain Superman in the new TV universe
first then Lex Luthor and it just makes
things so much more complicated I know
you guys would say that Smallville
totally did all those characters but
think of the new DC TV universe as
beginning with arrow like arrow is the
progenitor for all these new modern
shows so everything has to be
reintroduced for the first time again
just like in the comics after the new 52
reboot that doesn't even begin to get
into what is canon what is not canon
across all these networks essentially
they're loosely based together like all
the four ones that I'll be doing videos
for this Titans one is kind of uncertain
right now that means that older shows
like Smallville aren't canon anymore so
consider those stories as like an
alternate universe so big question for
you guys who do you want the villain to
be in this new Teen Titan show remember
it can't really be someone that's been
used by another network recently each
network isn't doing characters that the
other networks are doing so since we're
within like the four week premiere
period of some of these TV shows I'm
gonna be doing bonus videos starting
next week for all them so subscribe to
get everything
it'll be Gotham arrow flash and
Constantine if you do have any special
video requests for any of these TV shows
just write it in the comments but right
now you can click here for my breakdown
of the latest arrow season 3 trailer
you can click here to learn about some
of the new flash villains coming in
season 1 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives